all right that's really it but first
it's time for visit a big red chair
who's there hello hello hi what's your
name
[Applause]
I didn't get your name what's your name
what's your name Bev Bev oh [ __ ] that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah I've got ya in a red chair I'm
covered in a red shirt no but I've got a
story for you I went to see Frank
Phantom of the Opera oh yeah I really
didn't want to go but my husband he
always liked musicals I always had my
suspicions but you never like to ask
anybody wait you just say - so I don't
know a fella in a masked woman screaming
shamefully fell down I don't know if it
was supposed to anyway the thing I
remember clear as day and she says truth
a woman sat next to me she [ __ ] herself
[Laughter]
excuse me Pavan I said it yourself
she said she was so engrossed she didn't
know she said that she showed us you're
right I don't apologize I have [ __ ] me
so but it didn't it didn't impede their
enjoyment of the Sun and that to me is
the marker good theater yes
[Applause]
[Music]